>> EASTERLY CHANCE FOR THEE ZON.
CANADIANS COME AWAY WITH IT.
THEE ON THE TWO OTHER CANADIENS.
HERE IS JASPER.
SHOTUST SAID, LIKE, YOU FOREGOT
HOW FAST HE IS UNTIL YOU SEE
SEVERSON.
GREAT VISION.
TIME IT PERFECTLY.
GIVES HERE TO BRAD.
HERE IS JASPER BRAT. WEAVE HIS !
JACK HUGHES PASS.
IT'S RIGHT ON THE TAPE OF JACK
HUGHES.
PICKS IT UP.
T
DEFE MORE HUGHES.
OVER THE LINE.
THE DISH FROMEVERSON AGAIN.
GIVES IT TO THE CAPTAIN AGAIN.
HE SNAPS ONE ANDS TO BRAT.
BRAT ACROSS.
SHOT BY HUGHES. AWAY.
DEVILS COULDN'T GET ANYTHING
THROUGH.
BU
WOOD.
KAUFFIELD AGAIN.
HOFFMAN IS.
SHOT FROM THE CIRCLE..N LOW A
McLEOD WILL LOOK TO GET IT OUT.
SIEGENTHALER AND DEVILS BREAK
OUT.
PLAY IT ACROSS.
GATHERED BY HUGHES.
HERE IS JACK PLAY, IT'S
PITLICK
THE SHOT.
ONE MORE LOOK. AHEAD.
AND HERE'S BARON ON
MIKE HOFFMAN DAWS WITH A QUICK T
NICO.
LOOSE PUCK.
SHOOTS -- OFFE.
>> THE CAREER NUMBERS
THERE.
AND HERE WE GO.
THOMAS OF SIX.
BRAT.
IN DEVORAC FOR THE
CANADIENS.
IN ON
LIKE THAT THAT
IS NEAR THE